worth it season finale today we're doing
sandwiches yes we're taking sandwiches
international which is why we are in
Athens Greece that's right we flew all
the way here just kidding this is
actually Nashville Tennessee which
happens to have a one-for-one
reproduction of the Parthenon
one might ask what is the more important
part of the sandwich the contents or the
bread that is a debate we are going to
be putting to bed this episode - bread
not it's mostly gonna be about meat
though so it's ok your hopes up bread
lover because today I'm worth it we're
gonna be trying three sandwiches in
three cities I have three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at his price
that's six slices of bread Nashville the
home of many amazing things but we're
gonna be focusing on the hot chicken
that was founded here we're gonna do one
of the original spots called Bolton's
spicy chicken and fish
[Music]
hi I'm Dolly and you're at both of spicy
chicken and fish Nashville Tennessee
Motors is a local owned and operated
restaurant my husband Bolton is named
after his uncle Bolton hope who had a
chicken shack at the bottom of sugar
Street Bridge years ago what is so
special about that recipe that makes
Bolton's both my secret ingredients that
I exposed to the public is love joy
peace and happiness but don't know a lot
of people getting a lot of pain when
they come here and they get the hot
chicken
the expression in hurts so good yeah
that's what they say then you might go
on a daze or you may start giggling what
are the different spice levels that you
can get at Bolton non spicy right now
Wow medium hot is extra hot which level
do you like to eat Wow which one should
we
okay today we will be having our famous
if you never had a bone-in sandwich it's
a proper way to eat it this is going in
our sandwich bonus in your samples this
is real chicken not process to me I love
it we marinate our chicken quarters at
least 24 hours sometimes 48 roll it once
it's white shake it a little bit put it
in the skillet you're using a skillet
and not an industrial large fryer why is
that because they hold flavor but while
you cook it in its skin it gives it a
whole different taste if you can't tell
I'm nervous and I want to make sure I'm
not gonna make a mistake by ordering the
hot we should order the hot right if you
don't have a hot pepper tolerance no but
if you want to go for it I'll send you
there the residents can stay two to
three days even if you shower you cannot
touch your eyes and you'll wash your
hands before you potty for your hook
your girlfriend all of it
have you ever seen a better meat to
bread ratio than that you know that's my
kind of sandwich some people are like
sandwiches are all about the bread like
I was reading up on how Sean Evans from
hot ones prepares himself he says never
eat with the empty stomach so let's have
a little mac and cheese to start the
please shares
that's great we're doing both avoiding
units please eat chicken all right ready
for this right yeah
Cheers
well that's nice oh that he level is
nice yeah it's sooner than that lives
okay all right look how the spice is
sticking in my hands don't rub your eyes
it's not my eyes I'm worried about it's
so good Wow what in my face right yeah
okay you just came back from this done
okay different pockets of the chicken or
spice a little differently I may have
started a more mild area I'm gonna go
like a normal family I'm gonna try about
this oh
I unintentionally kissed the chicken
it's kind of like taking a cold shower I
like feels really good but you kind of
like doing a little dance to get
yourself to the other end yeah the first
tier is dropped for me really see this
right here corner of my eye oh oh no
it's just my eye oh no
your eyes oh god oh no oh no
[Music]
my I know it doesn't burn oh
you were warned that's all I'm gonna say
somewhere no thief no no and then
happiness oh
you know the special thing about this is
not really that it's spicy is that it's
expertly made fried chicken at a
ridiculous price point five fifty yeah
are you ready for the very hot no
same
so we just left Nashville or back in Los
Angeles that's my first time in
Nashville actually I had a great time
now gonna have our second sandwich and
we're on our way to the oyster dealing
stir is that binging with babish no way
that's not him that's him
no that Benji with babish yo
we're filming our last episode right now
all right enjoy have fun Thanks
so if you don't know who that was Andrew
Raya from binging with babish you
haven't seen their YouTube channel
pretty fantastic
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is Andre Guerrero we're at the
linkster we're gonna feature our oyster
pastrami sandwich today tell us about
the oyster what is this restaurant I
used to hang out here when I was in high
school it used to be Jim's burgers I
grew up eating this fast food I want to
do something different we deconstructed
the french fries the burgers even the
ketchup we make from scratch if that's
what we were gonna do fast-food
restaurant but we were gonna elevate the
food when I was a kid my dad used to
stop at this little Jewish rug store and
this old guy used to make pastrami in
the back the memory of that the smell
and the taste that was my goal that
pastrami from my childhood the fries my
brother was going to chef school in
Brussels they'd have these little street
vendors it just blew me away and I
thought God why can't we get good fries
here and they eat it with Nene so we
came up with this garlic aioli it just
seemed perfect to me we use ice bran oil
it gets a crispy very clean flavor and
that's what the Japanese use for making
tempura I know you guys are known for
the you've a milkshake ube is this sweet
purple yam that grows in the Philippines
there's a huge Filipino community here
I'm Filipino nobody was making has sweet
milkshakes and people went crazy for it
I'm hearing this story you have your
Filipino background your brother went to
Brussels this Jewish pastrami if
somebody was like what kind of food is
going stir make what is that it's a
representation of Los Angeles its global
global fast food yeah to you what makes
a good sandwich use all great
ingredients you can't make a bad
sandwich
scoop a milkshake for me and a craft
beer for you that it will they shake
that would do my obey shape I was hoping
you would
it's more of a role than a shake
yeah I'll accept that as a shake here's
oh
the show is so much better when I dance
my eyes are so crispy it tastes very
potato yeah it's really wild in the back
I saw them make this there's a whole
horrible things in it wait what yeah
it's not like just mayonnaise you know
it's like a whole other tasty paste oh
it's so creamy and they're fluffy no all
right let's get the same life situation
started oh my gosh this is a big boy
there is so much pastrami in here oh
[Music]
that's so frickin good the pastrami is
so good you know it's key about this has
that thick sandwich satisfaction without
the normal thick sandwich problems which
is like fitting in your mouth exactly
being able to flows down on it and get a
clean bite yes clean bite you glad you
just flowing out from the bottom well so
much pastrami but I can still taste the
cheese in the sandwich the slaw and the
mustard and the role in the onions this
is this great sandwich eating I can't
dance anymore that was a sick sandwich
we're here to try a very special very
expensive sandwich we have Rea our
cultural guide translator parfait
ambassador to help us out but before we
get to the very special sandwich we're
going to learn a little bit more about
sandwiches in Japan generally at a place
called Yoshida pan speaking a can
so this one it's not political it's
ketchup dressed pasta no I'm gonna get
that one I want to try that any what do
you want excellent choice obviously in
this kind of sandwich before no
kamikatsu which is a deep-fried ham I'm
gonna get a marketing because it's my
favorite combo unco it's sweepings and
buttery spread
by my I get this out this is probably
the best packaging of a liquid I've ever
seen in my entire life like a abstract
capri-sun
why are you pointing at me milk dang
this fun is the most inviting food I've
ever seen you give us
mmm
mmm-hmm how's the spaghetti Steven it's
kind of confusing me I need a form right
now it is actually good well it's an
interesting texture right
all right but now we're going to
potentially one of the greatest
sandwiches of all which is gonna be a
20,000 yen ride wag you cutlet sandwich
naka-meguro narimasu Rocky Maivia cutlet
sandwich does she tend to know
innovative oh she must over Gil Murphy
echoing oh don't mind me argue a second
here emetic do you project to the touch
ever touch it whatever very much they
wanted to maturity that I can walk to
not go babysit or billion sandwich
anatomist totin especially today was a
mess a super huzzah body must agree
America you can also not available until
time remember a bit over tonight yeah la
casa
when you could have an idea a guru -
Manohar we are clearly more umami got
beginner Nicky DeVito suka Meredith day
I like you know a stove and some when
Yasir I do you cannot see D they take
your stay super Jewish in a comfortable
as you are dated I came along as 2/3 you
do things
Catina Wow
it's also not happy my inner self under
a semi I mean you are so no Nick Romano
any kind of assault I didn't come to the
moral Tammy me do you want Obon is to
take your study bus
take us away Steven season finale final
restaurant in Tokyo $200 wag you mop
yeah Kobe Chateaubriand sandwich you
know what your Chateaubriand means right
I had no idea the Chateau is like you
know your large estates where you
plant your flag what is Breann brilliant
the brilliant home really beef you're
making I'm making this up but shelter
it's a castle Briana it's a person's
name according to chef Briana's castle
it's Brian's castle we're having some
Japanese craft beer I had a porter all
[ __ ] on the sandwich stay away -
season five - Steven Kampai
yeah that's tasty I did not expect it to
be so thick it has to be fixed even it
has to be picked okay all right let's go
ready
[Music]
Wow that was so incredibly soft that was
absolutely right the bread is firmer
than the B my mind wants to think it's
an ordinary sandwich and then when I bit
into it
it's extraordinary yeah like Narnia you
know the bread tells my tongue it's
lunchtime let's eat the sandwich yeah
but then the beef tells my tongue holy
crap what the what is going on so the
chef's
some of the recommendation to enhance
the flavor I think okay oh we did
okay but do a little bit of little
pizzazz yeah this I can smell from this
distance the sauce like the truffle its
truffle right oh it's truffle salt
I mean I mean this guy knows the way to
my heart
[Music]
every time I'm like yeah it's tender no
big deal and then I put it in my mouth
and uh ha ha ha ha all right I'm gonna
finish this off yeah I'm really doing
the end here Cheers Stephen goodbye
wow that was a super good sandwich
Wow
[Music]
did you have the pitbull welcome back to
Los Angeles Steven or journey has come
to an end and Adam thought it would be
appropriate to end this with ice cream
sandwiches yeah which is honestly
probably my favorite sandwich what
cheers Cheers Steven
another race of melty so Steven we've
been to three cities we've eaten a ton
of sandwiches it's also the close of our
season what was the most worth it
sandwich it's given price hot chicken
sandwich at Bolton's you know made me
feel alive is great juicy my worth it
winner is the oyster pastrami everything
they do is so carefully made it tastes
so freakin good in your mouth it has to
be the only surfer man Adam what was
your worth it winner
Annie you know where they learn
huh uh-huh
five and four water fear
thanks for watching this season season
five high five
yeah I read a little tiny bump bum boom
season five that's a wrap that's the
that's the other piece of bread on the
end of our season first piece of bread
big meats last piece of bread a sandwich
video in the middle all the atoms Oh oh
yes